that wherever you find a kafir you kill
them indicating whereever you find
non-muslim you kill it's a barbaric
religion and one of the most famous vers
quoted is of Surah TBA chapter number n
verse number
five and these critics they say
including AR shui he writes in his book
The World of fwa he quotes 9 vers number
5 and says that the Quran says wherever
you find a CF into bracket he means
Hindu that you kill
them and if you open the Quran Surah
chapter number 9 vers number five does
say that wherever you find a kafir kill
them but he's quoting a verse out of
context if you read the context the
first few verses of Surah Toba chapter
number n it speaks about a peace treaty
between the Muslims and the mushrik of
Makkah and this peace treaty was
unilaterally broken by the mushrik of
Makkah by the time Allah subhana wa
ta'ala reaches verse number
five he tells the mushrik the enemies
that you put things straight in four
months time otherwise a declaration of
war and in the battlefield Allah says
that when the cfirs when the enemies
come you fight and you kill them so this
verse is a verse which is revealed in
the battlefield that when the enemies
come to attack you don't get scared
fight them kill them now any army
General to boost up the moral of his
soldiers he will but naturally say they
don't get scared fight and kill the
enemy he not say that don't kill the
enemy don't fight so this verse is a
verse which is revealed in the
Battlefield andon Shi from verse number
five he jumps to verse number seven
because Surah 9 verse number 6 has the
reply to his allegation verse number six
says that if the enemies seek aym if
they seek peace don't just give it to
them escort them to a place of
security so that they will hear the word
of Allah subhana tala the most merciful
Army General today will tell his
soldiers that let the enemy go but Allah
says don't just let them go escort them
to a place of secur
it and further if you analyze that all
the major religious
scriptures all the major scriptures they
talk about fighting falsehood with
truth all the major scriptures if you
read the Bible in the book of Exodus
chapter number 32 it speaks about
fighting in the Bible in the Book of
Numbers Chapter number 31 speaks about
fighting in the Gospel of Luke chapter
number 22 Jesus Christ speak says that
take the and fight same thing with
Mahabharat it's a full epic talking
about fighting bhagat Gita is advice
given by Shri Krishna to Arjun to
fight Arjun says in bhagad G chapter
number one verse number 43 to 46 that
how can I kill my cousins I would prefer
getting killed unarmed than fighting my
relatives so Shri Krishna says in bhagad
chapter number two verse number 23 he
says how can such impurities come in
your mind they don't want to fight how
can you become so
important BH chapter number 2 vers
number 31 32 33 says that you are a
chhatria you should fight only if you
fight will you get
Paradise the moment I tell a Hindu of
bhagat Gita he tells me no but this
fight is truth against
falsehood so I said same thing Quran
speaks truth against falsehood the
moment I give the example of BH Hindu he
understand and then he says okay then
Quran has got no
problem so to a Christian you have to
give the example of the Bible to the
Hindu you have to give the example of
his religious scriptures come to Common
terms and if you analyze every country
it has its laws even India has it laws
in India it is prohibited to Rob it's
not allowed by
law it is prohibit to rape but yet
people are robbing yet people are raping
so what do they have they have a police
force police force to see to it that
they can punish the criminal we have a
military if enemy comes to
fight every country has a military force
has a police force so similarly what the
Quran talks telling the Muslim that when
the enemies come you be prepared and
fight so when every country in the world
has a police force has a military force
so when Quran tells the Muslim that in
your state even you have a force we
should be ready to fight the enemies so
what's the harm in the
Quran we should realize that the Islamic
Sharia it's perfect
and if the
Khalifa gives an order the head of state
to fight and if he says all should take
part in fighting all should take part
irrespective whether he a doctor or
engineer that is the Jihad striving you
have no option that law is not there in
India and people
object that in
Islam why does Islam take Jaz attacks
from the non-muslim and in the Islamic
Sharia there are even rights of the
non-muslim we can give a talk on that
and I write articles every month in one
of the Haj magazine Saudi Arabia the
rights of non-muslim Islamic Sharia time
will not permit to speak about this in
detail but just allegation about jazia
that how come
Islam takes Jia from the non-muslims if
you know the background of jazia why it
is taken you will appreciate it see
jazia is the tax taken from the
non-muslims who agree that they agree
with the rule of the Muslims we agree
that you are the rulers
and the thing the Jaz has taken that in
an Islamic State if you are a Muslim and
if the Khalifa tells that you should
take part in Jihad or take part in the
war fighting of the falsehood it's
compulsory you have no option
irrespective whether you're a doctor or
a engineer or a lawyer when a non-muslim
gives desya
the Islamic State gives him protection
and the J is how much just a couple of
hundred rupees hardly and the Islamic
State gives them protection if anyone
attacks you we'll protect you you need
not take part if someone giv me the
option that should I fight if the
enemies come or would you prefer paying
100 rupees and staying peacefully at
home and getting protection I would
prefer the second pay a couple of 100
rupes and sit at home relax I have got
protection everyone is protecting
me so actually this J tax is just to
acknowledge that fine we accept that we
under protection and they get
protection and similarly if you analyze
there are various vers in the Quran
which talks about non-muslim rights
Allah says in the Quran
in chapter number 16 verse number 8 that
as to those kafirs who do not fight your
faith and do not drive you out of your
home Allah advises you to deal justly
with them for Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
does does not like those who are
unjust but as to those cfirs who fight
your faith verse number n of Sur chapter
number 160 as to those kaf who fight
your faith and dve you out of your home
Allah forbids you to go to them for
protection so if the non-muslim is good
he doesn't fight
you and doesn't drive you out of your
home you have to deal with them justly
and there are various rules and rights
even for the non-muslims this is the
total Islamic
Sharia irrespective if a Muslim if he
harms a non-muslim even he gets
punished if a Muslim robs from a non-m
muslim's house one k of gold his hand
will be
cut that is Justice if you analyze
Islamic Sharia is not barbaric it is
perfect
and the Sharia firstly lays down rules
what good things should do not Rob not
rape Etc but everyone will not
follow so for them the punishment is
laid
down but the complete Shar also includes
one of the pillars of Iman the fifth
pillar of IM that is life after
death Allah says in the Quran in M
chapter number 67 verse number
two it's Allah who has created death and
life to test which of you good deeds
this life is the test for the Hereafter
and life after death is compulsory for
Iman without that IM is not complete
why and there are many people who a life
after death it's illogical many people
don't believe in life after death many
people don't believe in almighty God how
will you convince them
logically The Logical argument is I've
given the talk on Quran and modern
science and I've said that that the
Quran contains more than 6,000 verses
out of which more than a th000 verses
speak about science now if you analyze
all the verses that speak about science
approximately you can say 80% today
science tells us 100% correct because of
advancement of Science in all these few
hundred years today's science tells us
that Approximately 80% of whatever Quran
speaks about sence is 100% correct the
remaining is 20% Which is ambiguous
unknown one amongst them is life after
death s hasn't reached that
far to prove that there's life after
death science hasn't proved that there
is H of Heaven science hasn't proved the
existence of Jin so there is 20% yet
science hasn't proved what the Quran
mentions so is it that I'm blindly
believing life after that I say it's a
logical belief my logic says that when
80% of whatever the Quran has said is
100% correct and 20% is ambiguous
neither right neither wrong my logic
says that inshallah even this 20 person
will be right it's a logical
belief and one of this 20 person is life
after
death now how to
convince a
person in another way
about life after death suppose there's a
person who does not believe in life
after death and does not believe in
almighty God how do you convince him I
would like to ask your a question is
robbing good or
bad robbing is good or bad
bad all say bad is raping good or
bad who says it is
good no one out of 4,000 people no one
says robbing is good no one says ripping
is good all of you agree yes okay let's
do an
exercise
suppose I am a Smuggler
hypothetically I'm a Smuggler a very
powerful Smuggler I'm a robber number
one in the world top
robber and you are those people who
don't believe in life after death don't
believe in God now if you are a person
who doesn't believe in God doesn't
believe in life after death and I am a
Smuggler a top Smuggler very intelligent
who believes in reason and logic I tell
you that robbing is good I'm telling you
robbing is good I'm a very logical
person I'm a very scientific person I'm
asking you all of you so loudly said
that robbing is bad robbing is bad I'm
telling you give me only one logical
reason why robbing is bad and I will
stop robbing I am a very logical person
I'm intelligent person I believe in
science only give me one logical reason
or scientific anything that why robbing
is bad and I will stop robbing can
anyone give me one logical
reason you're taking other people's
right I agree with the brother I'm
taking somebody else's right when I'm
robbing I'm robbing th000 rupees from
him I'm taking his right it is bad for
him not for me I told you prove to me
logically why it is bad for me if I take
somebody else's money 1,000 rupees I can
go and have dinner I can go to a f star
hotel I can see a movie it's benefiting
me I told you give me one logic in it is
bad for me it is bad for the person
who's being
robbed the brother said that I'll get
punished by the police police will catch
me brother the police is in my
pocket the ministers in my pocket I told
you I a top Smuggler number one in the
world if you're a small robber if you
rob you'll get
caught I'm a tough Smuggler you know the
Mafia the police is in the pocket the
ministry is in the pocket the ministers
the judges are in their pocket they're
on the
payroll give me one logical reason why
it is
bad
huh you should remember starting of the
exercise I told you that you those
people who do not believe in God do not
believe in Hereafter I'm a Smuggler you
are trying to convince me that robbing
is bad give me one logical reason only
one Haram Haram Haram according to you
so you don't
Rob it's not Haram according to
me if it's Haram according to you don't
Rob if it's prohibited don't Rob who's
telling you to Rob I'm telling you proof
to me I am a logic iCal person only one
logical reason give me why it is bad and
I stop robbing only one not two only one
logical with
logic you will be robbed very good
brother is intelligent somebody will rob
me brother I told you I'm number one
Mafia I've got 100 bodyguards 100
bodyguards standing behind the stage all
I've got ak-56
rifles if a small robber rob somebody
will rob him I'm number one in the world
I have got bodyguards no one can rob
me
no
reason I will die with
my I die with my weth even you have to
die and I have to die so what's the
problem everyone has to die will you not
die so before I die enjoy life even you
will die even I will die but before I
die I will stay in a five star hotel I
will have good food to eat what problem
even you have to die when I have to die
you have Consciousness or Consciousness
will not allow me brother my conscious
is very good I'm a logical person if
your conscious say don't drop you don't
drop I'm a logical person my conscience
is very clear what I'm asking you that
give me a logical reason if those
people's conscience is not to rob you
don't Rob my conscience says it is good
when I Rob I'm benefiting I can enjoy
life so why it is wrong it's
good
sorry what is
better he's saying that because I
haven't worked I'm getting Easy
Money ah he's saying it's easy money I'm
not working taking other piece of money
therefore I'm telling it is good easy
money Rob why do work hard see if I tell
you how to get easy money it's good or
bad it is good so all these reasons are
telling me it is good what I'm telling
you give me one logical reason why it is
bad and I stop robbing you cannot give
me a single all of you said it is bad it
is bad can't give me a single what
happened to the people of
chenai
sorry I can't hear you brother
you will be next generation of
America he says I have to be
Bush okay
fine
fine now all the Chan is
over brother said if I'm robbing I'll be
robbed I told you I've got bodyguards
didn't I tell
you I have got bodyguards no one can rob
me okay all Chan is over now let's turn
the tables
[Music]
over okay fine now all the chances
over I don't mind having
enemies no one can har me I have got
bodyguards now the exercise is over for
you now let's get to the answer now
let's get to the answer as I told you
that this was exercise that if a person
comes to you and tells you that how come
you can prove about the Islamic Sharia
this is the question you ask him now
let's turn the TBL is over turn the
tables over you are that
Smuggler hypothetically hypothetically
you are The Smuggler you number one and
I I'm a Muslim who's coming and
approaching you and if you are a
Smuggler you tell me that Pro to me that
robbing is bad if I tell you that the
police will catch you the police in my
pocket
if I say that you're harming somebody
else you say it doesn't make a
difference to me if you say it will bite
your conscience you say that I don't
have a conscience at all my conscience
is clean if I tell you that maybe
someone will rob you you say that I've
got
bodyguards the first thing I'll do as a
Muslim after all the argument is prove
to you the existence of Allah subhana wa
tala the reason a person who is number
one in the world supposed to be the top
Mafia and Smuggler or
robber for him materialism become
Supreme he thinks he the most powerful
the first I'll do is I logically prove
to him the existence of Allah subhana wa
taala which I've done in my talk is the
Quran God's word so anyone who sees this
video casset is the Quran God's word
with an open mind he will agree that the
most supreme power is Allah subhanahu wa
taala is almighty God so first I'll
prove to him that he is not the most
powerful the most powerful Allah subhana
Talala with the help of the Quran and
science Point number one point number
two after he agrees okay fine I agree
God is the most powerful then what type
of God is this nothing is happening to
me and he's right we have hundreds of
example in the world what top Smugglers
top robber nothing happens to them am I
right or wrong many people you get
hundreds of robbers and top people in
the world who lead a very luxurious life
nothing happens to them they die a
peaceful death yes some people get
killed some people get arrested but
there are many who die they enjoy life
and the die
peacefully his question is if your God
is so great why doesn't he
punish what type of justice is there
Allah says in the Quran inaha chapter
number four verse number 40 Allah subhah
wa ta'ala is never unjust in the least
degree he's never injust in the least
degree and you ask any person the moment
is not on the top when you prove to him
he's not on the top and if there's
Injustice done to somebody else he would
not mind but no one would want Injustice
to be done on them if someone D somebody
else's wife or mother and if someone is
put to death you call barbaric somebody
rapes our mother then we think the death
penalty is best so if it happens to us
he realizes that there should be Justice
any human being will agree that there
has to be Justice done but the question
is how can Justice be done in this world
everyone can't get Justice for example
example you may be aware Hitler
incinerated 6 million Jews how many 6
million Jews suppose you happen to catch
Hitler
today C Hitler today what punishment can
you give him what can you give him
maximum you can put him in the gas
chamber but that will compensate for one
what about the remaining 5
million 900,000 999 what about
them what about them what type of a law
is this is it a just
so Allah says in the Quran in Imran
chapter number 3 verse 185
that every soul shall have a taste of
death and the final recompense will be
on the day of
judgment and anyone who has been saved
from the Hellfire and enters the garden
he would have achieved the objective of
this world for this life is nothing but
mere chattles of deception so the final
kab final judgment is on the day of
judgment that is theab the final so the
only way you can prevent a mafia who no
one can touch here who ministers in his
pocket judges are in his pocket police
in the pocket is by punishment in
the this only can complete the full
Shar belief in the so the Sharia has
three levels number one
is that it gives a law don't Rob don't
rap number two if you Rob rape you get
punishment here number three because
those who don't want to follow the law
they can get caught they get punished
but every country doesn't have the
Sharia America doesn't have the Sharia
India doesn't have the Sharia so they'll
go Scot free so then they will get the
punishment in and if Allah subhana wa
tala has to give punishment to Hitler in
Allah says in the Quran Ina chapter
number four verse number 56 that as to
those who reject our signs we shall cast
them into the Hellfire and as often as
the Skins are roasted State we shall
give them fresh skin so that they shall
feel the pain so today SCI has realized
that the pain receptors are in the Skin
So if Allah subhana wa ta'ala wants to
burn Hitler 6 million times he can do it
he can even do it 12 million
[Applause]
times